[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوحوش
قال الاصمعي سمعت اعرابي يتبرع الى الله
بكلمات فقط عيون البلاغه
وايتمت جواهر قال كفى في عزه ان اكون لك
عبدا وكفى بالفخرا ان تكون لي
انت كما احب اجعلني كما تحب السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
في دلاله الفرق بين المراه والزوج ورد في
سوره مريم قوله تعالى على لسان نبيه زكريا
عليه السلام قال رب انى يكون لي غلام
وكانت امراته عاقره ونقرا في سوره
الانبياء قوله تعالى
فاستجبنا له وهبنا له يحيى واصلحنا له
زوجه
يلاحظ استخدام كلمه امراه في الايه الاولى
عندما كان الحديث عن امراه عاقر لا تنجب
ولكن بعد ما وهب الله تعالى لزكريا عليه
السلام ولده يحيى استبدل لفظ الزوج مكان
المراه ثقيل واصلحنا له زوجه جاء استخدامه
الزوج دالا على الاسره والانسجام والتكاثر
في سوره التحريم يقول الله تعالى ضرب الله
مثلا للذين كفروا امراه نوح وامراه لوط
كانتا تحت عبدين من عبادنا صالحين
فخانتاهما تظهر هذه الايه عدم الانسجام
بين النبيين
وامراتيهما فاستخدم السياق القراني لفظا
امراه بدلا من زوج وكذلك جاء الحديث عن
امراه فرعون في الايه وضرب الله مثلا
للذين امنوا امراه فرعون السبب انها كانت
مؤمنه وزوجها كافر
الخلاصه عند غياب الانسجام بين الرجل
وامراته لسبب ما يرد لفظ امراه فلا تكونوا
زوجا الا اذا صالحت زوجها وصالحه لها
والله اعلم
[موسيقى]
ارسل ابو جعفر الى الشيخ العلامه سفيان
الثوري فلما دخل سفيان عليه قال ابو جعفر
سني حاجتك يا ابا عبد الله قال هو تقضيها
يا امير المؤمنين قال نعم قال فان حاجتي
ان لا ترسل الي حتى اتيتك ولا تعطيني شيئا
حتى اسالك ثم خرجت وقال ابو جعفر القيد
الحب الى العلماء فلقطوا الا ما كان من
سفيان الثوري فانه اعيانه ثرارا
وملك بمثلي سفيان ولكن الخير باقي في هذه
الامه
[موسيقى]
ضل لي اعرابي الجمل فحلف بالله انه ان
وجده باعه بدرهم لم تمضي ايام حتى وجده
فلازمه بيعه ربط في عنق الجمل في نورا
وسنه وهو القط كما تعرفون ثم قال السنور
بمائه درهم والجمل بدرهم واحد ولا ابيعهما
الا معا
هذا ذكرني بقصه الخروف الميت تعرفون ذلك
الرجل الذي ذهب من اجل ان يشتري خروفا ثم
قال له نحن عندنا خدمه توصيل يعني انت
تدفع الثمن وياتيك الخروف الى البيت او
ربما
لما رجع الى البيت وجد الخروف ميتا
وكان قد دفع فيه يعني 20 درهما او نحوه
قال
ستطبع اوراقي نصيب فطبع وقال الورقه بدرهم
وباعها وقال في يوم
سنعمل القرعه والذي تقع عليه القرعه سيربح
هذا الخروف
فلما باع المئه ورقه صار عنده 100 درهم
وبعدين عمل القرعه وقال للفائز هذا خروفك
فقال له الفائز ولكن الخروف طلع ميت فقال
هذا الدرهم ثمن تذكراتك التي دفعتها على
الورق هذه من قصص الذكاء التي احيانا
تمر على الناس من غير ان يشاوروا خاصه
فيما يتعلق بامور الجوائز التي تتبعها
المؤسسات الكبر
[موسيقى]
الغليون انبوب للتدخين له راس مجوف يحشى
فيه التبر وهذه الكلمه فارسيه الاصل من
قليون
ومعناها ان رجيله
واصلها الاول من كلمه عربيه جاءت من
الغليان وسميت بهذه التسميه بان الماء
الذي يتحرك في
القاروره التي تكون في اسفل النرجيله
يتحرك هذا الماء عند التدخين كتحرك به عند
الغليان هذه كلمه عربيه ولكنها ذهبت ثم
عادت الينا مشوها مبناها ومغيره معنا
[موسيقى]
يقول ابن الدمينه من البيض حوراء والمدام
تبدت لنا من بين استار قبه كشمس تبدت حين
زال سحابها
فخلت وميض البرق عند ابتسامها وقد حال دون
الثغر منها نقابها
هذه نفس ما حكيت من البراقع يفتنني بس
طريقه فصل وقال عنتره العبسي ولقد ذكرتك
والرماح نواهل مني وبيض الهند تقطر من دمي
فوجدت تقبيل السيوف لانها لمعت كبارق ثغرك
المتبسم
وقال قيس بن الخطيب تبدت لنا
كالشمس خلف غمامه بدى حاجب منها
وظننت بحاجه
وقال محدثكم
تبدت
كشمس لم يكن في زوالها انات تسلم
[موسيقى]
ولا تقول اعتبره مخلصا بفعل اعتبر يعني
اخذ العبره من حادث او موقف يقول تعالى
فاعتبروا يا اولي الابصار
قل اكدت الامر ولا تقل اكدت على الامر
بالفعل اكد يتعدى بمفعول به مباشر لا بحرف
الجر واصل الفعل وكده
[موسيقى]
يستعمل الناس
يقولون قلعته من البيت او ولعته من البيت
او العمل او تركته بعنف وقد اشتقت منها
تعبير انقلع بمعنى اذهب مسجورا والكلمه من
اصل معروف هو قلع ورد في لسان العرب القلع
انتزاع شيء من اصله كانهم شبهوا الطرد
العنيف باقتلاع عنبه من جذوره كي لا يعود
مجددا
يشيع بين العامه استعماله قال في غير معنى
القول فيقولون قال بثوبه اي رفعه وقال
بعينه اي او ما وقال به اي ضرابه وقال
بيده ايمدها وقال بالماء اي صبه وقال به
اي قلبه وقال كذا ايمان ويقال كذا او قال
كذا ويميل بجسده كل هذه الاستعمالات عربيه
فصيحه ربما تستغرقون
القول في اللغه قد ياخذ كل المعاني بشكل
عجيب
[موسيقى]
ادخل العرب التانيث المعنوي على صفات
الذكور للمبالغه فقالوا رجل راويه للشعر
اذا كان ينشده ويحفظه وقالوا رجل علامه
اذا كان كثير العلم ونسابه وهو العالم
بالانساب
ومجزامه وهو الماخوذ من الجزم وهو القطع
ومعناه انه كثير القطع
للمفاوزين
والطرق يقولون رجل مطرابه وهو كثير الطرب
شديده ويقولون رجل لحاله وهو الذي يخطئ في
كلامه فلا ياتي بصواب فيه ويقولون رجلا هي
بهجه وذلك الاحمر
هناك قصه طريفه تتحدث ان رجلا جاء الى
معاويه وكان معه ولد له وكان هذا الولد
كان معاويه ياكل فادعاهم الى الطعام وكان
هذا الولد
ياكل بلقب كبيره جدا فيقال ان معاويه سال
الرجل في اليوم التالي قال ما فعل ولدك
التلقامه بمعنى الذي يكبر اللقمه
العسكري اورد في الفروق اللغويه فرقا بين
التكرار والاعاده التكرار يقع على اعاده
الشيء مره وانا اعادته مرات الاعاده تكون
للمراه الواحده الا ترى ان قول القائل
اعاد فلان كذا لا يفيد الا اعادته مره
واحده واذا قال كرر فكان كلامه مبهما لم
يعرف ما اذا كان قد اعاده مره او مرتين او
مره
يقول العرب في امثالهم لليدين وللفم فما
قصه هذا المثل وكيف يستخدم هذا المثل يقال
عند الشماته بسقوط انسان فيقولون وقع فلان
يقال لليدين والفم اي اسقطه الله على
اليدين والفم وقد تكون الشماته بسقوط
حقيقيا او معنوي روي عن عمر بن الخطاب رضي
الله عنه انه اتي بسكران في شهر رمضان
فتعثر السكران بذيله فقال له عمر لليدين
والفم او ولدنا صيام وانت مفطر ثم امر به
في حب
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر عن نصيحه
تتذكرونها دائما وتذكرون بها انفسكم
وغيركم فيما لاستعرض معكم بعض ما وصلني من
المشاركات هذه مشاركه من عرب يقول اتق
الله حيثما كنت واتبع السيئه الحسنه
وخالق الناس بخلق حسن
ومشاركه من عبد الاله يقول الفرص في
الحياه تاتي مره واحده ولا تعود تغتنمها
انا اختلف معك والله يا عبد الاله الله
سبحانه وتعالى
اكرم بكثير من ان يجعل لك في الحياه فرصه
واحده فقط
[موسيقى]
يقول ان الحياه قصيره صحيح يا لطفي الحياه
قصيره ولكن الذكر للانسان عمر ثاني عندما
يترك الانسان اشياء يذكر بها بعد مغادرته
لهذه الدنيا
سهير تقول دع الايام تفعل ما تشاء وطب
نفسا اذا حكم القضاء
ومشاركه من احمد يقول رحم الله امرا عرف
قدر نفسه
دانيلا تقول استعن على قضاء حوائجك
بالكتمان عبد العزيز قول الله تعالى ادفع
بالتي هي احسن
وسعد الهمالي تقول استاذ من موريتانيا كنت
في نقاش معه حول مشكله فانا صحني حين علقت
ان وقوع المصيبه خير من انتظارها فاجابني
قائلا بل تجنب المصيبه هو الخير
امنه ناصر تقول ولو اجتمعوا على ان يضروك
بشيء لن يضروك الا بشيء قد كتبه الله عليك
مشاركه من امل تقول ومن يتق الله يجعل له
مخرجا ويرزقه من حيث لا يحتسب
وبشرى لا تحسب المجد تمرا انت اكله لن
تبلغ المجد حتى تلعق الصبر
مشاركه من رنين احسن الى الناس تستعبد
قلوبهم تطال مستعبد الانسان
ومشاركه اخيره من
سلمى كن جميلا ترى الوجود جميلا الى
الماضي
اذا بهذه المشاركات اصل معكم الى ختام
فقره وسمو اذكركم بانتظام تاملات الجزيره
عند نهايه كل المشاركه
اليوم عندما ينبغ احدهم نقول هذا فلته
زمانه بمعنى ان الزمان
صار عنده تفلت عن المالوف فخرج هذا
النابغه وهذا الرجل الذي احدثكم عنه كان
في ذلك الوقت فلتت زماني قال عنه طه حسين
واصفا حبته ان نقديه الرجل الذي لا يخطئ
الى كلمه الا حلال على راسه عفريت
لعلكم عرفتموه هذا الكاتب والشاعر
والاستاذ الجامعي محمد زكي عبد السلام
مبارك المعروف
زكي مبارك
ولد في سنه اثنتين 92 و 8000 في محافظه
المنوفيه في مصر وضع العائله الميسوره اذن
له بالالتحاق بكتاب القريه اولا لتعلم
مبادئ القراءه والكتابه وحفظ القران ثم
الانضمام الى الازهر الشريف وتعلم اللغه
الفرنسيه هناك حصل على شهاده الاهليه من
الازهار
زكي مبارك شارك في مظاهرات ثوره عام 1919
بملابسه الازهريه تقبض عليه ولم يفرج عنه
الا بعد ان كتب اقرارا بعدم الاشتغال
بالسياسه
التحق زكي مبارك بكليه الاداب في الجامعه
المصريه لنيل الاجازه حيث لم يسهل عليه
طبعه الحاد ومناقشته الدائمه لاساتذته
مهمته
رصد مرتين على يديه طه حسين الى ان تحصل
على الاجازه فاكمل دراساته العليا وتقدم
برساله بعنوان الاخلاق عند الغزالي لنيل
الدكتوراه هذه كانت الدكتوره الاولى التي
تمنحها الجامعه المصريه
عين بعيدا في الجامعه لكنه سافر على نفقه
الخاصه الى باريس والتحق بمدرسه اللغات
الشرقيه في جامعه السوربون وحصل على
دكتوراه ثانيه
هذه المره كانت الدكتوره بعنوان النثر
الفني في القرن الرابع الهجري حيث اختلف
مع اساتذته هناك الاستاذ المشرف عليه
وبعد ذلك اعلنها عاليه المستشرقين
مع عودته الى مصر صرفه الى تحضير دكتوراه
ثالثه عن التصوف الاسلامي فحصل عليها من
الجامعه
المصريه ومعها اطلق على نفسه لقب الدكاتره
زكي مبارك يعني مش دكتوره واحده ثلاثه
بدات علاقه مبارك بالكتابه الصحفيه باكرا
فكان يكتب اسم الفتى الازهري وهو في
الثانيه والعشرين عمل في جريده الافكار
وتولى رئاسه تحريرها لفتره ومع عودته من
فرنسا نشر في مجله الادب العربي وكان
صفحته بعنوان الحديثه
فيها خاب معركه الادبيه مع معظم الاسماء
اللامعه في زمنهم مثل طه حسين عباس العقاد
والمازني وسلامه موسى واحمد شوقي واحمد
امين ومصطفى صادق الرافعي وما تراك احد
ومع ذكر طه حسين العفريته الذي يحتاج في
راس زكي مبارك رد عليه فقال الرجل الذي لا
يخلو الى قلمه
تلك كلماتك وانا راض عنها وبها مختلفه
الذي يحتل راسه حين اخذه الى قلمه ان يكون
هو الحق ان كان ذلك انت تشهد لي بالعبريه
والقول هو ما قال طه حسين وهل تكون
العبقريه الا من نصيب من يخاصم رجلا مثلك
في سبيل الحق وما المنفعه التي ارجوها من
مخاصمتك وانت رجل تضر وتنفع
بالاضافه للدراسات والمقالات كتب مبارك
شعرا غزليا بمعظمه ومن ابياته يقول ايه يا
فتنه الوجود سلام من مشوق متيم القلب عام
لو يشاء الهوى حوت في ضلوع حائمات على
صباك حوامل
من الوجه يشقى بغراما مؤججا
خصوماته لم تجعل حياته العلميه سهله
السياسيه المعارضه الاحتلال الانجليزي
وسياسات القصر والحده لسانه التي لم
تتوانى عن مخاطبه وزير المعارف حينها بمثل
هذه اللهجه يقول له لن اطيع امرك الا حين
يقوم الدليل على انك وزير فقد اسلمت امور
الوزاره الى قباني بلا ميزان
من هنا نفهم تنقل حياتهم المهنيه في اماكن
كثيره عمل في الصحافه والجامعه الامريكيه
وعين مفتشا للمدارس الاجنبيه في مصر لفتره
قبل ان يخرج منها
النقراشي وزيرا للمعارف والسنهوري وكيلا
للوزاره فسافر الى العراق عامله بالتدريس
في دار المعلمين العليا والقامه الانديه
العامه
الدراسات الادبيه ودواوين الشاعر
والمقالات وكثير من الكتب نشر بعد وفاته
من مؤلفاته رحمه الله اللغه والدين
والتقاليد البدائع الاخلاق عند الغزالي
الموازنه بين الشعراء ذكريات باريس
الفني في القرن الرابع الهجري بدانا
العشاق ليلى المريضه في العراق التصوف
الاسلامي ملامح المجتمع العراقي
يقول عنه يوسف القعيد لا اعتقد ان شخصيه
ادبيه
اوضحوا في ملامحها من شخصيه زكي مبارك
من اليسير الوصول الى شمائل هذه الشخصيه
من اثاره وكتاباته فهو اسرح كتابنا
المعاصرين في الحديث عن نفسه
يقول زكي مبارك يا مصلح الساعات يا مصلح
الساعه هب لي من الساعه عمرا ولو ساعه لكن
ساعته انتهت وهو في الستين اذا كانت وفاته
سنه
1952 اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
تهنئه الى صديق
الاصدقاء نحب ان تهنئهم بالاعياد وبشهر
رمضان المبارك وبمناسبات كثيره
وبعضهم لا نكتفي بان نرسل له الكلمات
المكروره
ما نسميها بالرواسب التي اعتدى عليها كل
عام وانت بخير وينعاد عليكم
عندما يكون الصديق اديبا يزيد عليك من اب
هذه
الصياغات
شهر رمضان المبارك
اتى رمضان فلتهنى بشهر يعود عليك في مر
الزمان يعود عليك والدنيا نعيما وخيلك لا
تكل ولا تعاني وسيفك في المواقف ذو زئيرا
وازهر منه قلبك وليدان السلام
[موسيقى]